do you ever experience shame when it
comes to your sexuality
and where do you think it stems from
okay so okay this one okay
[Applause]
[Music]
when did you lose your virginity how was
it
okay uh looking me wrong was amazing i
had fun and i
joined experience but i wish it was
somebody a little bit more special
but you know the first time i had anal
sex it was i believe
sophomore junior year it was not for me
it was pretty painful
and we were a little unprepared too so
yeah we're both 16.
no one can really do it at their place
so it was kind of
not in a place you should probably be
doing that i was 19 and i was in austin
texas and i was visiting a friend who
went to school there
and i met this man on tinder and we were
talking for a little while i went to his
house
and then we had sex the first time and
then like recently i checked on like
instagram he's like married now with
like two kids and like great
thanks i feel good do you always have
the same roles in bed
are you exclusively at top or bottom or
can it change interesting question
i'm pretty much uh bottom i mean i have
topped
i'm not putting it on my linkedin my mom
thought i was a top
and i had to correct her and she's just
like what
she's like my son bought like it broke
her heart i swear i broke her heart
so when i first started having sex i was
i guess more in the bottom position
because that was just like what people
expected of me
i i think look young and i'm small and
i'm relatively
um not very hairy so people put me in
that category of like i have to be a
bottom and i have to do this and i have
to be a certain way
it's frustrating i like to think i'm a
person of the people so i just will do
what i need what needs to get done to
make sure that everybody's happy
if they prefer one thing's like okay
well then i guess i'll do the other
thing i can kind of go
either way i just need love i'm kidding
does sex hurt
depends if you both like communicate and
talk and chat and they get the vibes
going
then no i almost always try out and
avoid anal sex
it's a whole complicated process just to
do it and
and then it ends up not even being that
pleasurable for me
sex should be pleasurable so if it's a
little bit of discomfort you can work
past it
um with a lot of lube relaxing
communication
i haven't bottomed in a very long time
so
even when i the thought of it you know
as much as i crave it sometimes it's
just something that i try to avoid
i am a survivor of rape so it's just
getting into
the idea of bottoming is you know
feeling submissive at that moment is
just not something
that i'm still comfortable with at times
my partner will want to keep going and
i'm like no
it hurts we can't keep doing this or
like it's gonna be really bad
and that's totally okay don't be afraid
to stop whatever you're doing
if you're in pain have you ever had a
sexual experience with
women um no uh
never have never will i've only kissed
girls i've never had
anything besides that i've hugged girls
um oral oral and then after that i was
just like
i don't know what's in there uh once it
was like at a party
a little a little drunkeny it was all
right i mean i'm not gonna say it was
bad but it was just like you know once
was enough sexuality's such a spectrum
so for me it's something more
like oh why not i'm not super interested
in it but like that could be fun
i'm open to it i'm like you know i'm
saying like if like the
opportunity where to arise i
want it to be a threesome so that way in
case
i don't like that i have somewhere else
to go
how many sexual partners have you had
i want to say more than 50 the normally
exact number
maybe like 10 to 15. total sexual
encounters
are 323. it's not all anal sex it's some
i one of the encounters is like making
out with someone on the dance floor
a lot of my friends do they're like oh i
only had sex with
seven girls or whatever i'm like that to
me that that seems so low
and i mentioned oh it's like probably
around 30 or 40 and they were like they
were shocked about that like
30 or 40. that's a lot i'm like is it
there is a big hookup culture in the gay
community but i feel like
it's really more so maybe because we
don't really get the opportunity like
how a lot of
straight people do people kind of be out
and proud
and in certain places you still can't be
you know like or you can be but it's
dangerous
i think that combination along with the
fact that there was the aids crisis
there was some suppression
of sexual activity in the gay community
i think like we're almost like in
what one can consider like a gay
renaissance right now
from when i was 17 and 18 i was a hooker
in philly
and i had a list of all the dates that i
went on the 116 clients added up to like
160 something dates and that was the
money that i
saved to move out here four digits
probably
and there's nothing wrong with that is
it hard to find something that's more
than just a hookup
yes i've never had a boyfriend who is
willing to love me openly
like i've never had anyone be like
angel's my boyfriend
like it can kind of make you question
like
you know am i the issue here and i think
that for a long time
i thought i was until i realized i was
like no i was like i
i'm not the issue here it's the other
person being so obsessed with the
perception of
others and like i can't worry about what
everyone else thinks in this world or
else i'm never going to be happy
the gay community likes to promote like
you know it gets better and like
you know supporting each other in
actuality
it's different than that you know i you
know experience
racism in the gay community more
which is kind of weird and for me it
hurts more because in the gay community
my heart's on the line
it's really hard to like get someone
who's like really into like investing
the time and effort in a relationship
and then like there's some people who
say they are
but like then you like you show your
interest and they're like
you're a little too interested and it's
like okay i personally have encountered
men who
you know are into me one second and the
moment i say i'm not gonna hook up
they're
you know calling me all these names or
you know telling me off eventually i do
want to have you know a family
kid so having a partner would make that
possible if you really want it and you
really are like you know
praying about it manifesting i think it
could be possible you know
it's hard not gonna lie but it's not
impossible sure
any advice for someone's first time
um lube uh
breathe for my tops
listen to the bottoms gay porn makes it
look so easy like it's instantaneous but
like the truth
is that it's not things are supposed to
go out not in clean out
and eat lots of fiber you don't need to
clean all the way up in there you just
need to clean out the lower hall like
the foyer
you don't need to do like the second
story in the roof and also there's so
much more fun to be had than just
penetrative sex so
if it's hurting do something else do you
always practice
safe sex yes and no
when it comes to hookups i will always
practice safe sex
you just never know i'm not a stranger
to a slip up
so you know totally about the lighting i
was like yeah yeah
no uh and i should and everyone should
be on prep everyone should be using
condoms and stuff like that
and if you don't know what prep is uh
it's a pill you take so if you come in
contact with the hiv virus it can't
replicate in your body
but that does not protect you from other
you know stis
like hepatitis herpes
gonorrhea even though i'm on prep and
i'm practicing those practices that are
safe i just feel more comfortable
practicing safe sex with a condom i had
a gay uncle and a gay aunt
and my parents always told me condoms
will save your life and they're probably
dead
do you ever experience shame when it
comes to your sexuality
and where do you think it stems from
okay so okay that's not okay even before
i
knew what gay was i knew you didn't want
to be it
and i'm around certain family members
maybe like my uncles or something like
that you know where i kind of like
play down maybe like my mannerisms with
like my hands or the way i talk or say
certain things
something that i'm still struggling with
being comfortable
when i was raped i
wasn't very open to the idea of sex
especially because when i told my
friends they kind of blamed me for it
and when i did try
being more open to having another sexual
experience with a guy i almost got raped
a second time
and that was very
very troubling for me and not knowing
why these things were happening to me
in a way it made me feel like i deserved
it like who goes through it more than
once right and it's taken a very long
time
i still feel some shame for me at least
it's become very difficult to even think
of the idea of sex
when i was young it definitely affected
me more because i was so confused and i
didn't know what like being gay was and
i'm getting
all this like negativity though being
gay is bad you're going to hell blah
blah blah i'm just like
i just wish that people could not focus
on like
who i'm bringing to bed but focus on
like their own life i have a lot of
friends and family who do accept me but
um
my biological outside really doesn't um
i don't care who you are to me i'll cut
you off
like you you can be my family
you can be my great grandma i don't care
like if you can't love me for me when i
am not judging you
i'm good what is something that you wish
you learned
sooner things about anal sex and like
how to prepare yourself what to expect
and how to be safe with it i wish that's
something that i would have got told
instead of something i had to kind of
learn through trial and error with
hookups
i've had some situations where i was a
bit uncomfortable or consent wasn't
fully talked about or discussed or it
was a little bit blurry
or i did something that was a bit
reckless and irresponsible
instead of like shying away being like
don't do that be like hey if you do that
here's a helpful hand on how to
experience that safely
and have fun doing it
[Music]
you